c'est un bad buzz qui a pour le moins
entaché la rentrée politique de marlène
schiappa un petit post anodin qu'elle
n'imaginait pas prendre une telle
ampleur
en cause une vidéo un message qu'elle
aurait posté sur instagram pour faire la
promotion d'un salon de coiffure où elle
a ses habitudes
merci adriano et vassan de highness braz
et pour ce lissage qui répare les
cheveux et va donc me permettre de
gagner de précieuses minutes avant
chaque matinale tout de suite accusé de
faire un placement de produit la
ministre a d'abord déclaré qu'il
s'agissait d'un piratage avant de
reconnaître que nous mais qu'il ne
s'agissait pas d'un placement de produit
puisqu'elle n'avait rien touché pour
faire ce poste hier soir sur notre
plateau vincent martens le gérant du
salon coiffure a bien confirmé que
marlène schiappa était venu dans son
salon mais a aussi précisé qu'elle avait
réglé la facture et qu'elle n'avait rien
touché pour faire cette publicité en
ligne
de par la position match à part on
pouvait pas se permettre de proposer ce
genre de gratuité entre guillemets
aujourd'hui nous détenons des
informations importantes qui font office
d'un retournement de situation
s'agissait-il vraiment d'un lissage
brésilien
combien at elle vraiment payé quelles
vont être les conséquences de ces
nouvelles informations c'est l'heure de
l'enquète de baba
j'ai en ma possession documents ou les
documents me permettant d'arriver à la
conclusion
tout d'abord je tiens à dire que marlène
schiappa est pas un cas isolé
1 à nombreuses stars ont fait des
lissage brésilien
tout comme par exemple
mon ami et frère
franck gastambide également mon ami
philippe etchebest gad elmaleh
ou encore bernard laporte il y a même
igor bogdanoff caf un lissage au nom
tout regarder ça pourrait même voir sur
cette photo qui l'a fait 4 lissage ehpad
sur l'eshop on embrasse les séries sur
les réseaux sociaux plusieurs
internautes dont babar le rhinocéros que
l'on brasse c'est comme babar mais c'est
pas des défenses un rhinocéros ont
relevé une éventuelle fake news de
vincent le coiffeur de marlène schiappa
ce qu'il dit 150 euros la facture qui a
été adressée la ministre cette facture
on peut lire que le son a coûté 120
euros avec 30 auront en plus car le son
a été réalisée par adriano à adriano la
star des lissage brésilien
c'est comme neymar mais pour les
lissages sauf que certains sont allés
sur le site et on veut que le soin
rituel renaissance comme indiqué sur la
facture coûterait 250 euros pour des
cheveux longs ou 350 euros pour un
lissage brésilien
sauf que j'ai enquêté à j'ai enquêté et
j'étais enceinte du bulbe de marlène
schiappa et marlène schiappa n'aura
henry n'était pas réalisable issac
brésilien met un soin réparateur est là
on appelle rituel inclusion pas dire
qu'on met un truc dans les jouets en
même temps
et coûte 120 euros adriano ne pas très
ne pratiqueraient pas ce soin sauf au
crillon vip d'où la taille de 150 euros
qui n'apparaît pas dans leur grille
tarifaire
j'ai envie de dire enfin
et encore une fois une enquête rondement
menée et depuis depuis joly depuis cette
affaire un bien sûr de lissage brésilien
sais pas si vous avez vu depuis 24
heures il ya un truc qui bossent
énormément sur les réseaux sociaux sur
un truc de lissage également un truc de
coiffure
regardez c'est ça des problèmes de
cheveux tout ça c'est terminé
alors non spa dont j'aime pas j'aime pas
ce côté franche-comté frangipane
j'aurais préféré un tie and dye je suis
pas non je suis pas franchement je suis
pas alors on allait non c'est pas non ce
n'est pas d'hier mais mylène farmer mais
j'avais des terrains des ordures et
mylène sartoux j'aurais préféré quelque
chose que réussir une bulle ne sais pas
je ne passe pas alors mal
oh non je suis pas trop nourri les
points car on dirait dernière sarah on
dirait romain judas flée nous rallumons
06 mar je suis pas je suis pas fait
quelque chose de fait le vite je suis
pas là bas ça pas du tout là je sais pas
[Musique]
marlène schiappa la qualité ministériel
pour vos chéris toute la lumière sur
cette affaire
est ce que cette affaire vous a choqué
dit la vérité ikea
oui bien sûr bien sûr ce qui vous a
choqué dans la sphère maintenant bien
évidemment que ça aurait pu être
choquant si effectivement la faune de
produits oui si ça m'était un placement
3 dit c'est pas possible pour une
ministre
elle est déléguée à la citoyenneté c'est
d'aider le pont du ministère de
l'intérieur
ça aurait été grave mais là vous avez
rétabli la vérité vous avez bien fait
nommer non mais et vous activerez les
bons points et les mauvais points
honnêtement c'est pas tellement à
l'image d'un mini de sa wii pour ralenti
de doute les cheveux et leurs échasses
et moi la cegelec
je vais très bien vu cm avait
franchement pour un mix de la république
dans le contexte actuel où c'est
vraiment un bordel monstre partout faire
ça franchement c'est pas c'est pas
l'auteur viendront chaleur et gérad
mille effectivement taille mini un peu
mal mais moi je remercie marlène
schiappa parce qu'enfin on parle d'autre
chose on parle de lissage brésilien ça
fait du bien ça m'a fait du bien pour
tout le monde pour ceux de cosi de
barrio mais là on parle d'un lissage
brésilien et moi je trouve c'est une
bouffée d'air frais ça ferait du bien
sophie coach qui est de retour ma chérie
c'est encore plus beau en 2021
un corbeau là où ça fait plaisir
vous serez l'adoma non mais il ya un
petit problème de communication quand
même pas séché palace ministre j'ai
effectivement chargé notre citoyenneté
donc c'est un petit peu on s'en fout un
peu de ses cheveux donc c'est marrant ça
fait un buzz etc - les chemises jaunes
qui intéresse la mairie communique d'une
manière un peu étrange
elles se devaient peut-être quand même
s'attendre à ce qu'une réaction à ce
niveau là que ce soit placement de
produit ou pas d'ailleurs c'est simple
mais à un moment donné c'est un tout
petit peu je pense mal venu deux fois
oui elle est pas chez l'oréal quoi fin
donc oui mais c'est surtout que sable ou
douze tableaux h/24 et oui ça va lui
faire gagner de précieuses minutes
elle a passé deux amis chez le coiffeur
et en falloir des matinées pour minuit
or et 2002 elle a perdu chez le coiffeur
donc c'est pipeau on voit qu'on prenne
un bon début je me suis dit merde mais
n'a pas autre chose à [ __ ] que de
manier une photo comme ça c est l un des
nouveaux pigeons la vie après en
revanche je me suis dit mais les
mimiques le fait que sur les réseaux ça
peut devenir une véritable polémique et
des normes et à t'en foutais coiffard
foutaise s'il ya une loi foot est il ya
une loi je veux pas faire mon avocate à
deux francs six sous sur le conflit
d'intérêt qui dit qu'une ministre ne se
doit jamais de défendre une entreprise
plutôt qu'une autre et c'est ça qu'on
lui a reproché aussi beaucoup à ce qu'il
parait qu alors non il paraît que dans
le monde du lissage capillaire était au
collège on le dit aux membres du
gouverment guy lux moi c'est pas ce que
les gens ce n'est pas le fait qu'elle
soit pays dont on sait qu'elles prennent
le temps oui un de corridors sur la
crise de vente et comme c'est les
mairies bain dans un salon de coiffure
et franchement le ton qu'elle écrit ça
vraiment un placement de produits est
franchement ce n'est pas le rôle du
ministre de le ralentir
santes habillée coiffée comme des sacs
on est les premiers à montrer du doigt
les noms et ratisser les chez nous ici
on est coiffée et habillée comme des
sacs permis comme c'est pas ça c'est
qu'il ya un moment donné on a reproché
aux politiques d'être complètement
déconnecté avec des jupes et bavarder
giscard c'est vrai elle elle est normale
elle réfléchit pas à mon avis c'est
plutôt ça je pense qu'elle est assez
lent balmont c'est maladroit ces malades
démocratise un peu la politique et elle
se pose moins de question qu'on le pense
assez de temps en temps loi mien c'est
pas la première fois
je pense pas qu'elle calcule tout mais
je pense qu'elle vit normalement et de
temps en temps mais elle se fait prendre
le doigt dans le pot de complexes fondés
sur le soit dans la belle maman comme on
dit on arrive quand même parce que
marine chapelle tout comme elle respire
m'a bien sûr
ben quand même c'est moi je trouve que
c'est la tergiversation
ces justifications à tergiverser et
stupide il voulu dire ouais ok bull est
désolé c'est maladroit ne te dira mais
non mais c'est pas moi ça oui oui oui
c'est ça avait en tout cas on a fait
toute la lumière sur cette affaire de
lissage de genia et j'espère que ça y
est vous avez toutes les infos voilà moi
aussi sachez que j'en ai fait un petit
et c'est très content vraiment fusion ce
à quoi on dirait plutôt une petite la
fusion non ok t'as plus dont vous allez
voir bientôt ses deux ans